donc là on a une cuisson grand cas c'est
donc le sucre est prêt on va pouvoir le
verset oui et donc charlie et la
chocolaterie
bienvenue dans l'univers gourmand de
nicolas viol est issu d'une famille de
confiseurs forains se passionnaient de
bonbons réalise ses premières praline à
l'âge de 12 ans et achète sa première
machine de calissons à 16 au 20 ans plus
tard
l'artisan réalise son rêve partager le
savoir faire authentique des métiers de
la confiserie tout en exposant ses
innombrables pièces de collection datant
du siècle dernier
le son du jour la traditionnelle
sucettes de fête foraine une
démonstration loin d'être anodine pour
lui on a toujours fait une sucette nos
berlingo et donc de pouvoir refaire ce
battage à la main au crochet c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui me tient à
coeur
pour l'auditoire hypnotisé par ce
magicien du sucre place à la pratique
on est bien on façonne alors attention
je compte le nombre de tours ces cinq
taureaux par sucette pas plus sans
oublier la dégustation jeu superbe on
vraiment en plus on voit comment ils
sont en train de les faire donc c'est
impressionnant et puis je me régale de
revoir des anciens bonbons voilà cdd
soutenir aussi qu'ils reviennent les
goûts et les souvenirs
pour nicolas violée l'expérience est une
réussite parce qu'ils étaient sympa
c'était vraiment de de pouvoir faire
venir les visiteurs dans un lieu unique
et qu'ils puissent voir un maximum de
fabrication de confiseries et qu'ils
puissent prendre du plaisir parce que
c'est jour tout ça c'est que ce soit
ludique et et qui est des souvenirs en
commun avec les parents et les enfants
le conservatoire de la confiserie sera
ouvert au public
sept jours sur sept pendant tout l'été
pour les plus gourmands d'entre vous pas
de panique vous pourrez même repartir
avec quelques petites douceurs
[Musique]